c'est le début d'une nouvelle journée et
le début d'une nouvelle vie on s'en va
maintenant la voiture tu viens à 30 ans
mathieu la combi père de famille est
maintenant ministre de toutes les
familles du québec pour vous toutes et
que j'ai pas choisi mais si j'avais eu à
choisir c'est ce que j'aurais choisi
comme une star la famille je pense que
c'est taillé sur mesure pour que je
remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
ministre de la famille un emploi taillé
sur mesure pour un homme proche de ses
enfants
a campagne électorale on travaille fort
puis ma conjointe holt est vraiment
exceptionnel puis ça a été dur la
proportionnelle bon et coupé des enfants
pendant déjà quelques jours donc de voir
à quel point ils étaient contents de me
voir cette journée-là s'échauffent que
moi ça ça me remplit de bonheur c'est un
beau souvenir de son enfance difficile
ne le prédisposait pourtant pas à une
carrière politique
né à repentigny dans un milieu éprouvés
par la maladie mentale et la pauvreté
il a fréquenté plusieurs familles
d'accueil jusqu'à ce qu'un oncle et une
tante le prennent sous leur aile
je pense foncièrement que ce qu'on a
vécu ça nous définit par ce que vous
savez quand on est plus jeune
à un moment où on a besoin d'encadrement
et que cet encadrement mais peut-être
moins présent ça nous force à avoir
beaucoup de détermination si on veut
réussir il a appris à se forger une
carapace dont il aura sans doute besoin
plus que jamais comme ministre déjà la
semaine dernière les journaux est allé
au grand jour ses problèmes financiers
sa famille une pause été épargnés à
commencer par sa conjointe et sera
toujours pour un satellite heures
baptême puis elles avaient de la peine
de se voir comme ça à la une des
journaux puis je la comprends maintenant
on a dû avoir cette discussion là qui
est parce que c'est arrivé beaucoup plus
vite qu'on
le pensait après des études en
journalisme et en sciences politiques à
l'université d'ottawa avec vous à la
barre du tva nouvelles
il devient en 2014 présentateur du
bulletin de nouvelles locales en
outaouais
mon travail avec des bonnes le défi qui
l'attend maintenant et grands françois
legault a fait du dépistage des troubles
d'apprentissage un axe central de sa
campagne électorale et s'est engagé à
créer des maternelles quatre ans partout
au québec
en plus d'offrir plus de places en
services de garde l'objectif c'est la
qualité on en voit ce qu'on a de plus
précieux à la garderie au cp1
on veut que ce soit un milieu stimulant
mais son rôle de ministre promet-il ira
bien au delà de la gestion des garderies
mon rôle au gouvernement ce sera bien
sûr de mener certains projets de loi de
mener à bien certains programmes
je pense que ce sera aussi de garder un
oeil critique sur tout ce qui se dit
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres pour être un peu l'avocat des
familles pour vraiment faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un aspect famille dans les
décisions concrètes je t'aime pour
porter la voix des familles au sein du
gouvernement il devra sacrifier une
partie du temps qu'ils consacrent à la
sienne by ap entend les amis son voeu
des jeunes autour de la table du conseil
des ministres
ces jeunes sont souvent des enfants puis
il faut réussir à accommoder ces gens là
pour qu'on soit capable de les avoir
parce qu'on doit avoir notre place on
doit vendre place autour de la table
c'est quoi ça être ministre et pratiquer
la conciliation travail-famille voeu
pieux ou objectif réaliste
ok on y va le ministre lacombe on fera
l'expérience en effraie ici hugo
lavallée radio canada québec